[Music]
what are three things that every
minimalist must consider to create a
more sustainable life well you have the
three r's in in the book and you expand
it to i think there's like nine of them
or ten or i forget what the final
thought is
and so
i i don't like this sort of um
overly simplistic level of thinking if i
just do these three things but then of
course there is sort of the 80 20 rule
whereas like
what is the low hanging fruit here and
so maybe you could talk about three
things for your average person
or a handful of things it would make
sense to live a more environmentally
friendly life oh oh wow that's a big
question
um the first thing i would say to people
is do an audit of the way that you live
because what i talk about in the book
yeah there's 12 different r's 11 and 12
are kind of together and yeah a lot of
us can kind of work our way through that
but i've also had conversation with
people that have said uh what what
things do i need to buy to become you
know more environmentally friendly or
what do i need to do to become more
environmentally friendly and the first
thing i sort of say is well how do you
live your life
you know you don't need to buy a
reusable coffee cup if you never get
take out coffee
but people look at the instagram and the
pinterest and like oh you know all of
those you know shopping guides 10 things
you need and it's like well no straw is
another one
i need to get a reusable straw i go
great why
i hate straws right yeah me too well i
saw that video of the turtle with a
straw up its nose i go yeah that's
horrendous so when was the last time you
use the straw
and they go oh um
87.
and the thing is that most of us are
able to pick up a glass whatever and
drink something with our mouths and not
need a you know a straw of course some
people do need straws for medical
reasons
some things are much more pleasurable to
drink with a straw i.e things like you
know a milkshake for example trying to
sort of drink milkshake can be a bit
problematic in a bit you know all over
the place
but most of us don't need a straw most
the time so a thing like that the first
thing i'd say is do an audit of your
life okay what do you need
yeah and also what you don't need so
like we say refusal is like the first r
refusing what don't you need yeah then
you can start to think about what you
can reduce okay right so i've done the
refusing now what can i think about
reduction what can i do to reduce the
amount of materials i'm using um the
single use elements that i have
but again you could think okay well i
could say to people will ditch all the
single-use packaging and go to a refill
store and get loose produce so don't buy
you know sweet peppers in plastic get
loose peppers and they'll go yeah i
can't do that cause i don't have a store
nearby
well yeah you kind of need to understand
the environment you're in
you could say to somebody you know ditch
your car and walk everywhere
great but if it's five miles from where
you are to the nearest store are you
gonna walk that all the time right not
gonna happen so the template for one is
not the template for the next person so
the first thing is always
um to figure out exactly where you are
and then figure out what you can do and
then it kind of goes from there so there
isn't really a magic three you know
three is the magic number
um
there isn't it depends on you you're
just examining your life and figuring
out what you can do that's the first
step did you enjoy this standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalist
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100 percent
advertisement free